Thanks in part to the San Diego Comic-Con,
July saw the release of some of the biggest
movie trailers of the year so far.
From a tantalizing first look at Godzilla:
King of the Monsters to full-blown trailers
for blockbusters like Overlord, Shazam, and
Fantastic Beasts 2, July came in like a lion
and left like a kaiju, leaving a trail of
explosive movie mayhem in its wake.
In fact, there are almost too many to keep
track of, so here's a rundown of all the best
trailers from July 2018 that are guaranteed
to get you excited.
A Prayer Before Dawn
So far, A24 is the studio that can't seem
to miss.
They've been behind Oscar winners, underground
favorites, and blockbusters alike, and 2018
sees them continuing that trend with A Prayer
Before Dawn.
Following a British boxer who's sentenced
to stay in a violent Thailand prison, the
film looks like a gritty character study and
a thrilling drama that won't pull any punches.
Early screenings have already garnered A Prayer
Before Dawn an impressive Rotten Tomatoes
score, and mainstream audiences will get the
chance to witness the inspiring story when
it hits theaters on August 10th.
Patient Zero
After a relatively infection-free couple years,
zombies are breaking out on the big screen
again with Patient Zero.
Matt Smith plays an American soldier who can
communicate with the infected.
His job is to sit down and chat with the zombies
in an attempt to figure out how the whole
plague works.
But he meets his match when one zombie seems
to be different from all the rest.
It turns out that the zombies probably aren't
zombies after all, they're more like smarter
humans who happen to be really violent.
"I don't think that we're the disease.
We're the cure."
Can humanity survive against a better version
of themselves?
Find out when Patient Zero goes straight to
streaming on August 14th.
Assassination Nation
Seeming to revel in its own controversy, Assassination
Nation released its second trailer in July
and provided more glimpses into what's shaping
up to be a really weird movie world.
The film centers on the breakdown of civilized
society in a small town after a hacker releases
a bunch of emails and texts sent around by
the residents.
It's all out war in the sleepy suburbs after
that, and the trailer descends into a montage
of Purge-like violence between neighbors and
friends.
Take a look on September 21st.
Bohemian Rhapsody
Each new trailer for Bohemian Rhapsody reveals
more details about the story, more glimpses
of Rami Malek as Freddie Mercury, and, best
of all, more Queen songs.
The hard-rocking biopic follows the band from
its humble origins to the sold-out stadiums,
with a hard focus on frontman Freddie Mercury.
"Roger there's only room in this band for
one hysterical queen."
But of course, there's a dark side to every
story, and the latest trailer for Bohemian
Rhapsody spares a few seconds to show that
it's not all foot-stomping, crowd-pleasing
fun for this rock quartet.
Bohemian Rhapsody doesn't look like it's going
to shy away from anything.
Find out when it premieres on November 2nd.
Overlord
Despite all the rumors and speculation, producer
J.J.
Abrams has always said that Overlord isn't
a Cloverfield movie.
Nobody believes him, but that's what he's
saying, at least.
So maybe we can all just enjoy it for what
it is, which is a World War II zombie movie.
Is that so bad, really?
The trailer opens with a plane full of soldiers
flying over the beaches of Normandy.
Almost immediately, they're shot down, sending
a few of the unlucky troopers parachuting
deep behind enemy lines.
That would be bad enough, because Nazis, but
it turns out that there have been some devious
Nazi experiments going on behind closed doors,
putting the intrepid band of soldiers face
to face with horrifying monsters.
It looks like a bucket of fun, and you can
check it out when Overlord hits theaters on
November 9th.
Boy Erased
Joel Edgerton made his first foray into writing,
directing, and acting all in the same movie
with 2015's The Gift, and his upcoming film
Boy Erased will see him back in all those
roles.
This time, he'll be tackling the story of
a young man forced into gay conversion therapy
by his overbearing Baptist father.
While Edgerton has a supporting role, the
main cast is anchored by Nicole Kidman and
Russell Crowe, who star as the parents of
Jared, played by Lucas Hedges.
The trailer is an emotional gut-punch from
start to finish, with gripping performances
by everyone involved.
And the fact that it's all based on a true
story twists the knife just a little bit deeper.
Take a look when it lands in theaters on November
2nd.
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald
At this point, the Wizarding World of J.K.
Rowling couldn't be stopped even if you hit
it with an Unforgivable Curse.
In a year filled with huge blockbusters, Fantastic
Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald is still
one of the most hotly anticipated films of
2018.
Newt Scamander is back in action, and this
time he's being drafted by a young Albus Dumbledore
to help bring down the scourge of the wizarding
world, Gellert Grindelwald.
The trailer promises another magical adventure
filled with high-stakes wizardry and flying
carriage chases, and, of course, plenty of
fantastic beasts.
David Yates, who directed the first Fantastic
Beasts and the last four Harry Potter movies,
returns to helm the Crimes of Grindelwald.
Look for it on November 16th.
Robin Hood
Assassin's Creed heads to Nottingham in the
newest trailer for Robin Hood, the latest
take on the legend that's putting the aerial
acrobatics back in archery.
Kingsman's Taron Egerton stars as the hooded
arrow-slinger, with Jamie Foxx stepping in
as his right-hand man Little John.
Obviously, this rendition is taking a few
liberties with the source material, Little
John is Robin's combat trainer, Maid Marian
is Irish instead of English, and none of them
seem to be wearing tights.
"You gotta be a man to wear tights."
But we're assuming it'll make up for all that
with tons of action and epic bow-and-arrowing,
mixed in with just enough romance to keep
everyone's dates happy.
Robin Hood is scheduled to hit theaters on
November 21st.
Aquaman
Could this be the movie that defines the new
Worlds of DC?
We're ready for one of these movies to come
out and blow us all away, and so far, all
signs point to Aquaman being the one to do
it.
Experienced filmmaker James Wan is in the
directing chair, and Jason Momoa seems to
have all the right aqua-stuff to play the
king of Atlantis.
The trailer shows that the film will be pulling
from Geoff Johns' 2011 Aquaman comics, which
feature cool deep-sea critters called The
Trench and include a battle for the throne
against Aquaman's own half brother, Orm.
That's all good stuff, and the Aquaman trailer
seems to showcase plenty of style.
Right now, Aquaman is slated to hit theaters
on December 21st.
Alita: Battle Angel
December 21st is shaping up to be a battleground
for box office dominance.
Not only are Robin Hood and Aquaman hitting
the big screen that day, but they'll do so
right alongside Alita: Battle Angel.
With Robert Rodriguez directing from a script
co-written by James Cameron, this adaptation
of the popular manga is in great hands, but
that hasn't stopped fans of the source material
from getting kinda nervous.
Why are they so squirrelly?
Three words: Giant freaky eyes.
True to the manga, the main character's eyes
are at least three sizes too large, or approximately
the size of the Grinch's heart after he learns
the meaning of Christmas.
Once you start looking past the obvious, though,
it's hard not to hope that Alita: Battle Angel
could very tell turn out to be a great movie.
The trailer shows off a beautifully stylized
future world, and if there's a good story
behind it, then everyone may just end up forgetting
about those eyes after all.
Glass
Ever since the final scene of Split, audiences
have been waiting for the inevitable Splunbreakable
crossover to materialize.
Now that the first trailer for the sequel
is here, titled Glass after Samuel L. Jackson's
Unbreakable character, it's starting to look
like the wait was worth it.
The trailer doesn't hold back on the goods,
either.
It jumps straight into a shot of Jackson's
Mr. Glass, Bruce Willis' David Dunn, and James
McAvoy's Kevin Crumb sitting in a room together.
After that, the trailer spends most of its
runtime making sure everyone knows who these
people are.
Dunn is a bulletproof vigilante, Crumb is
a schizophrenic demon-man, and Glass is really
really good at planning stuff.
Finally, we get some hints that Glass and
Crumb are going to team up, and Dunn will
have to stop their evil schemes.
Check it out on January 18th, 2019.
Shazam!
Billy Batson may not be the most popular name
among the DC lineup, but even non-comics readers
are bound to know the name of his alter ego:
Shazam.
The first trailer for Shazam!
introduces the young foster kid who's granted
superpowers.
Like any kid, he just wants to have fun with
his new abilities, but when a supervillain
menace starts making his presence known, Billy
will have to get serious to save the world.
Zachary Levi seems like a great choice to
play the hero, especially since he seems to
have such a great on-screen vibe with Dylan
Grazer, who's playing Billy's foster brother,
Freddy Freeman.
Shazam!
strikes theaters sometime in April 2019.
Godzilla: King of the Monsters
July rewarded fans with two new looks at what's
to come for Godzilla: King of the Monsters.
The month started with a brief teaser showing
Stranger Things' Millie Bobby Brown trying
to get in touch with someone on a radio.
But the big reveal came when the full-length
trailer for the movie dropped, because this
time we actually got to see all those giant
monsters.
Director Michael Dougherty has also teased
that a character from Kong: Skull Island will
show up.
"But we do bring back one character from Kong:
Skull Island."
"Oh yeah?
Which one is that?"
"You'll have to see the movie."
Hopefully that "character" is none other than
Kong himself.
We'll be able to find out when Godzilla: King
of the Monsters smashes into theaters on May
31, 2019.